Líbano a las puertas de un total vacío
de poder el presidente Michelle aún
abandonó este sábado el Palacio
presidencial un día antes de que expire
oficialmente su mandato de seis años su
salida se dio en el Palacio de Bagdad de
beirut León hoy no es una despedida hoy
es una gran reunión hoy veo en todos
ustedes hombres de resistencia la
mayoría de ustedes estuvieron conmigo en
la primera batalla después de la cual
hombres estudiantes nadie terminó al
fusil ni a la prisión ni al garrote
siguieron resistiendo hasta que volvimos
a la patria que defendimos y pagamos con
Nuestra sangre el presidente cristiano
maronita según el sistema de cuotas
hectáreas de repartición de poder en
Líbano advirtió del riesgo de un caos
constitucional en el país y es que a
pesar de múltiples intentos el
parlamento no ha logrado acordar un
sucesor en el cargo cientos de sus
seguidores lo apoyaron en la capital
estamos aquí para apoyar al presidente
padre de todos estamos aquí hasta el
final de la vida porque es la persona
más limpia de la tierra y ningún será
como él es una persona patriótica que
ama a su pueblo y a su país sin embargo
Aún es una figura polémica y polarizante
comandante durante la Guerra Civil de
1975 y 1990 es admirado por muchos
afines a su fe pero otros lo critican
por su Alianza con el grupo islamista
chitas volab para subir al poder muchos
lo culpan de la crisis multifacética que
vive el Líbano presidió durante la
devastadora explosión del puerto de
beirut que dejó más de 200 muertos y por
la cual no hay rendición de cuentas
Además del colapso económico que en años
recientes llevó a la moneda local a
perder casi todo su valor frente al
Dólar y asumir a un 80% de la población
en la pobreza aún también informó de la
disolución del gobierno interino tras
aceptar su renuncia sin embargo el
actual Primer Ministro interino nayib
mikati aseguró que El Ejecutivo se
mantendrá en